bonjour alors où en est la manifestation
est l approche de la fin
on a fait samantha la manifestation
touche bientôt à sa fin en tout cas on
est bientôt arrivée à l'hôpital la
pitié-salpêtrière puisque c'est leo
point d'atterrissage ce rassemblement il
a commencé à 14 heures devant l'hôpital
allait caire et il est placé sous le
signe de l'amour puisque c'est la saint
valentin
aujourd'hui et c'est une déclaration
d'amour que veulent faire ici les op
l'ailé les médecins et les urgentistes
les infirmières une déclaration d'amour
pour sauver l'hôpital public qui est en
détresse depuis est des mois ils
manifestent depuis des semaines voire
des mois et malgré ce plan d'urgence
proposé par le gouvernement et bien ils
ne sont toujours pas satisfaits et ils
vont continuer à se mobiliser après
peut-être l'entendre derrière moi une
ambiance plutôt festive regardé
plusieurs ballons celui et de la cgt ici
à plusieurs associations également sont
présentes et le but était bien en boule
voyons ces images c'est toujours le
signe de l'amour des ballons en forme de
coeur des fleurs blanches sont
distribués également dans une ambiance
plutôt bon enfant il épate les syndicats
qui étaient présents ici il y avait
également des députés encore comme eric
coquerel de la non soumises qui était
présent je vous propose d'ailleurs de
l'écouter dans une situation où on fait
mine de ne pas confondre que aujourd'hui
la situation est dramatique vous avez vu
que plus de 1000 médecins ont remis leur
des missions administratives il faut
continuer voilà il se pensait que
celui-ci découvert constant corrigera
être paupérisation de la médecine
publique la santé publique donc très
certainement où vous vous sentez privé
pour choquer auront les moyens de ça
c'est le côté hop le corollaire est
peut-être encore tout à fait là y'a de
quoi se battent encore mais là j'ai
vraiment l'impression qu'on est en train
d'atteindre unis au delà duquel les
choses sont difficilement rattrapable
plusieurs milliers de membres des
hôpitaux ont répondu et présent ils sont
est ici elles manifestent depuis
plusieurs mois je vous le disais
plusieurs profils sont présents il ya
des enfants il ya des infirmiers des
urgentistes des médecins est également
il demande plus de considération une
revalorisation et des salaires et
surtout ils dénoncent le manque
d'effectif vous propose d'ailleurs de
les écouter qu'on est venus démonter
pour dénonce depuis des mois le manque
de moyens humains le manque de bras le
manque de lits le manque de
reconnaissance ne manque d'argent le
manque de salaires donc pour pour tout
le monde quoi parce que vous vient
chacun est concerné parce que le
bâtiment sis si on a des soignants et
qu'on est en mauvaise santé
on pourra pas prodigué des soins de
qualité quoi
moment reste sous opté pour ça
aujourd'hui on est là dans la rue pour
manifester encore une fois notre
mécontentement
on sait pas vraiment ce qu'il faut faire
pour que la ministre ait l'honneur
demande aux écoutes
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on aille tous cas
c'est quoi pour avoir un petit peu là
d'une vision sur nous et et que les gens
prennent enfin conscience coeur
l'hôpital est en train de s'effondrer
ac on sait plus trop quoi faire
aujourd'hui à part pas que mr de manquer
qui priorise le privé et qui est et qui
laisse le public s'effondrer clairement
si le manque de reconnaissance et de
respect de notre travail
les fermetures de ligne les patients qui
ne sont plus pris en compte en tant
qu'hôtel et on avait des salaires bas et
des conditions de travail qui se
dégradent de plus en plus vous l'avez
entendu samantha mécontentement détresse
en tout cas ce sont les mots qui sont un
revenu le plus souvent d'affaires de ces
manifestants agnès buzyn devrait les
recevoir à la mi mars en tout cas ils
continuent à battre le pavé à se
mobiliser pour sauver l'hôpital public
le cortège a débuté vers 14h il s'était
lancé dans les rues paris il arrive
bientôt à l'hôpital la pitié salpêtrière
c'est beaucoup mais un nouvel art pour
toutes ces précisions